dude
[Music]
okay what do you guys know about
Blackstone oh yeah the uh Blackstone
Black Rock it's like Stone was it
Blackstone that's not the private
military thing is it no no they're
they're two of the same well they came
from the same company BlackRock and
black stone is it the real estate one
well BlackRock is the largest of the two
companies right with over 10 trillion in
assets and then Black Stone has like 900
billion 10 trillion nothing hundred
they're the ones buying up all the real
estate I I I listened to an audiobook by
one of the founders of that group and
then one branched off and then started
doing like um a lot of the real estate
that we've been seeing that are buying
up all of the residentials and [ __ ] yes
so um there is
what's from Anthony no I'm I'm just
listening he just looks so mad about it
[ __ ] [ __ ] buying a ball so
Blackstone so you guys know what just
happened with FTX right like FTX
basically said hey we're well Sam
bankman free to say are solvent but he's
like we're fully solving I don't can't
believe what's going on right now with
U.S withdrawals like they should just
open them up and it's like you're the
CEO what the [ __ ] you open them up what
were you talking about okay so
Blackstone is limiting investor
withdrawals from its 125 billion dollar
real estate investment fund following a
spike in Redemption requests people
making a run right oh [ __ ] I wanna so
are they doing the same thing is that
why basically they're limiting
withdrawals that's all we know so far it
just happened today usually when they do
that it's not a good sign usually it's a
clear sign that that means that they've
been using people's money it's actually
a very good
business is great by the way uh
Blackstone paid me to talk about this
it usually means they have so much money
they don't want you to be irresponsible
they don't want you to get out before
it's get the getting's too good yeah
yeah it's gonna get better just hold
hold's about to go way up I know so um
only point three percent of the funds
net assets will be available for
redemption in December
0.3 I might as well just block it Jesus
Christ in October they received 1.8
billion dollars in Redemption requests
2.7 of the net asset value for example
so now only point three percent is going
to get taken out so so when two percent
is being redeemed they're like that's
too much well no the idea here is that
we must do point three percent no that
was normal right I'm normal month right
potentially and then now they're like oh
[ __ ]
we can't you know even handle it like we
can't handle that much we're gonna do a
point three percent okay so just to ask
maybe uh if I'm ignorant about it what
would they be using people's money for
they're over leveraged yeah but like on
what just purchasing other property and
real estate all kinds of [ __ ] they have
stakes and MGM brand and Mandalay Bay
um they have it's it's called Vichy
properties which is like a big
conglomerate holding all these assets so
people that are like a little bit more
skeptical and pessimistic about where
the economy is going
they think this eventually is gonna get
to the big Banks eventually Bank of
America Wells Fargo Chase is going to be
like you can't pull money out either
because we're all over leveraged on this
month and then they're gonna get bailed
out by the government and that's gonna
be all but all of us get [ __ ] because
we still have to pay but we deserve to
get [ __ ] because we're not that rich
yeah we deserve to get [ __ ] because
we're just the regular people so we
can't do anything like the way they can
so some people are recommending to start
pulling some of your money like actual
money out and start it at home not us
though we think that Blackstone is a
solid reputable company and savings get
passed down to the customers at Costco
so shop Costco during these hard times
are wild these days they're so
integrated I want a Costco brand deal
that would be the most long lasting
brand deal that we could ever have
tomorrow we need to come in and all
Kirkland Signature hoodies I would love
it
brand deal before though no because you
can't you can't detect it just happens
they don't need to yeah do you think if
we pretend to do Costco brand deals
they'll send us a season this is yeah
I think they'll be even more aggressive
this video is brought to you by Kirkland
that's that's like [ __ ] Ryan doing
the Rite Aid ice cream photos and then
being like oh you know what we gotta
stop this guy in a way what's the cease
[Laughter]
um so the estimated value of
blackstone's assets across Logistics
facilities apartment buildings casinos
medical office Parks is 69 billion
dollars
Forbes estimates wow and apparently 15.5
billion dollars in Revenue through 2022
thus far
[Music]
um so this is this is maybe you know
people you know a lot of people right
now on Twitter especially for the crypto
Twitter and everywhere they're going
holy [ __ ] is this an indicator is this
something that we should all be like
because it's the start of something yeah
the company as big as that is going you
guys can withdraw exactly what do you
think yes I think strong yes because
there are many times in my life where
there have been indicators like this and
then I was like no I think I can still
make money from it I think I'm good so
you you would really go to your actual
bank and start pulling money out because
what would be the most extreme safest
version I should probably actually try
that for once because like I've tried
not the that before that's a good idea
how do you do it
how do you even pull money out I've
never done it in in terms of what bank
not like cashing out like a pretty good
investment yeah yeah I have no idea I've
never done anything yeah what's that
look like that's what I'm saying I've
never done it before so like how do you
do it if you guys were to take your
money out what is the safest way to keep
cash you got to go to the bank and then
you gotta turn it into ethereum and then
you're gonna convert that into cash
that's the safety you gotta go to a
Bitcoin turn it into an inflationary
asset that can be printed non-stop as
long as now the safest thing is I just
give a bunch of cash like my dad and he
forgets where he puts a bunch of random
box of cash and [ __ ] random [ __ ] like
Escobar but in a small way because
that's what makes me nervous I think we
should invest in skateboards yeah
skateboards were so sick can we invent
and can we invest in finger skateboards
because I think Tech Decks it's cheaper
yeah because when people all lose their
homes and cars they still need to get
places and so skateboards are pretty
cheap well I don't think they can get
there with a little we're gonna be a
skating economy now while they're
getting places don't they need to do
something fun yeah they need to hop on
at the same time
that's kind of where I put it we're
thinking big pictures yeah yeah yeah I'm
thinking about the consumer so it does
this make you guys want to say oh I'm
gonna start looking into my own
financials to start it honestly does
make like when I hear more and more of
it does make you want to pull out like
some sort of really emergency savings
yeah like what would that
percentage-wise what do you think that
would be maybe like six months living
expenses or something
and then put it in like put it in a safe
or something do you think your bank
would stop letting you pay your bills
they'll freeze your account and be like
you can't even pay bills with this as
long as it doesn't say anything about
the Jews I think you'd be good okay
that's true how much stuff are you
saying I think it's your withdrawals any
guys talking [ __ ] about Jews hey uh
in what situation would a mass public uh
need to do a bank run on like major
central banks as China they just
they just oh yeah
and it's happening everywhere you know
it's like it's not like it seems like
something that's impossible because we
haven't seen it but it's literally like
huge nations are going through [ __ ] like
this yeah we saw we saw it with like
Russia you know we see in China but like
what is uh I saw it here
to the US version in this what happened
in a way
but thanks real estate crash but then
the banks didn't like take money a lot
of uh smaller Banks they were they
became insolvent like people are they
were doing Bank runs and then you would
see on the news like there would just be
lines out of credit unions and whatever
that people were just like I can't get
my money out bye bye Washington Mutual
how much of this do you think is like
the after effects of like lockdowns and
like covet and stuff do you think how
inflation is hell of that yeah right
like yeah it's a big decisions that were
made because of it I mean they stopped
the economy and then they printed mad
money why yeah the money printing
honestly bro a little bad call and The
Leverage Market give me a [ __ ] break
if I could complain about one thing
forever it's the leverage Market those
people are degenerate [ __ ] and I don't
like them I don't like people who play
leverage you go I'm not really on game
so people who play leverage you're going
to risk something you're borrowing money
to [ __ ] like you're sticking invest
with it taking something as collateral
but not nearly as much as you're
borrowing against it right because
you're leveraging it so you're going to
like say I'm like I put in two thousand
dollars okay but then I'm gonna uh 100x
leverage this so I'm gonna borrow way
more than that so you hate me well yeah
but exactly and and but we were [ __ ]
degenerate well I mean maybe he was like
wait not me but we were we were pretty
Joe Smiles what was the General remember
borrowing money and leveraging I
leveraged a little but I got out quick
that's the stuff I got up so just
Anthony yeah what are you talking about
Oh you mean you're talking about anchor
borrowing yeah oh yeah well but dude
we're not we're not leveraging we're not
true leverage traders in a sense that is
the sliding scale that does such like
you're not affecting the economy the
economy is affecting you still at that
size you know well no but but that's
right so you're you're placing a bet
you're you're saying I will um receive
this certain amount if my bet pays off
if I'm correct so say you're betting on
the price of Bitcoin I think Bitcoin be
35 000 by like this time well I'm going
to bet this much collateral right and
like stake that away somewhere and then
I'm going to place my bet and I'm going
to get paid off as a way higher amount
if I'm correct on my bet so it's like
sports betting in a way and that's the
problem is if the economy is hindering
on that on all these bets being made and
all these liquidations that are
cascading down the [ __ ] ladder now
you're in a real economic meltdown
situation which we have seen many times
this is a nightmare so we're headed that
way well I don't know because dude it's
it's always sensationalist [ __ ] right
you you never know exactly what's
happening it's always like what
someone's narrative is it's like Jamie
Diamond will tell you
you know of JP Morgan Chase Hill the CEO
he'll tell you be careful right now like
save money right now I think calamity's
coming but those guys aren't trying to
help like the [ __ ] average person
yeah we never know when a billionaire
tells you to do something like oh right
now you guys should be like spending or
you guys should be doing this like I'm
always skeptical got it because it's
like what skin in the game do they have
good for you but what about when a
realtor tells you it's the perfect time
to buy well that's different
you mean the ones that make commission
off
to all their best interests always a
perfect time to buy yeah there's never
like oh you shouldn't buy it that's what
ant says
but that's why I like well that's why my
whole uh game is targeting Market needs
Market needs is my [ __ ] game right
what does that mean so like looking at
what the market needs yeah
um give us an example I can use that in
a sentence please no so so when I found
ethereum or when I found Bitcoin even I
was like well this is cool because 2008
happened and I don't have faith in the
economy anymore right so then I was like
well you know bitcoin's kind of telling
you like that a completely different way
of looking at this [ __ ] and who knows
how to pan out look at that much on it
thank you Anthony
um
so then you know ethereum comes out and
I remember you know Finding ethereum
like 2016 I was like oh this is this is
awesome because two people can just
enter into like a smart contract they
can have an agreement with each other
that gets paid out when
um a parameter is met and they don't
need anyone to approve it you don't need
a notary or anybody to sit there and go
oh I I stamp this it's approved it's
done on the blockchain everyone can see
it and through consensus they can
confirm it awesome so then you know we
fast forward I get into OMG why'd I get
an OMG because cbdc Central Bank digital
currencies that is a market need like
whether you like it or not it's coming
[ __ ] and whoever is the first mover to
the market will be the big player in the
game and I thought because they were
working with scp-10x which is like the
biggest [ __ ] Bank in Thailand that
was that has like the king of Thailand
like like involved with it I was like
that is a dunk for me it rode um the
wave back was like the first biggest
mover but then thankfully I got the [ __ ]
out because I was like I don't know what
they're doing they sold the company I
don't know what's going on maybe it
didn't work out with cbdc's and that
happened so then I get to Luna Luna
what's it doing that's different right
uh tether the biggest [ __ ] name in
crypto actually if you look it up by
volume is tether Bitcoin ethereum who
moves more volume a day if you add both
of their volumes together tethers
so I'm like [ __ ] you need something that
is not that you can actually back by
something tether is not backed by
anything bitfinex doesn't open the books
up doesn't [ __ ] account for what's
going on with tether that's scary to me
like just like the regular cash game
exactly it's like cash and that's the
problem with cash it's not backed by
anything anymore there's no gold
standard anymore so I was like okay well
UST is interesting because they're
actually saying okay we're back in with
senior orange we know how we do this
like if every one dollar Looney generate
one dollar Luna gets or from every one
dollar of us you generate one dollar
loan gets burned there's a mechanism
there that's actually backing something
and then eventually they're like holy
[ __ ] we have a huge shortfall here we
[ __ ] have done so well in the market
cap because UST growth was so huge we
have to back it somehow using Bitcoin
they announced the mechanism they use
that mechanism to kill us we got killed
now what's my biggest thing fragmented
liquidity is it not panning out of the
market [ __ ] are we not seeing it all
[ __ ] day long
liquidity is the issue that's what
happened with FTX right
who's the biggest bucket they don't got
liquidity dog you can't cash out dog
who's the biggest liquidity performer
who's one of the biggest recruiting
Fighters
I do it all damn and do it every [ __ ]
time I will do it again does it every
single time never cashes out but does it
everything
but it's exactly right don't ever ask me
how to cash out I literally don't know I
was asking about it earlier but I know
how to pick them baby he's the guy at
the racetrack picking the winners and
then spending the rest and then doubling
down on the next one baby let's go
reinvest that's it
[Music]
[Music]
thank you